qui oggi abbiamo un pacco di pasta e uno
smartphone
Cosa hanno in comune questi due oggetti
bene entrambi possono nutrire
se per il pacco di pasta è abbastanza
semplice in fondo è il cibo simbolo del
nostro paese e ogni italiano ne consuma
in media 23 kg l'anno Io penso anche di
più eh
Invece questo aggeggio lo smartphone è
fonte di nutrimento Nel senso che da qui
oggi che passa gran parte
dell'informazione non solo ma anche
attività e relazioni che alimentano la
nostra quotidianità
e questo è un fenomeno in continua
crescita
pensate martedì prossimo taglieremo il
traguardo delle 8 miliardi di persone su
questo pianeta Ma già oggi abbiamo
8,2 miliardi di SIM dentro questi
aggeggi pensate più schede telefoniche
che persone è qualcosa di incredibile e
queste schede telefoniche producono dati
in continuazione è qualcosa che non
possiamo arginare
voi pensate basta uno smartphone del
genere anche per produrre dati anche
quando dormiamo così come produciamo
dati quando carichiamo una foto su
Instagram un video su Tik Tok quando ci
spostiamo nel traffico quando facciamo
un acquisto su una piattaforma di
e-commerce non solo dati personali
i dati vengono prodotti in continuazione
anche dagli oggetti dai sensori che
abitano le nostre città
in continuazione
Ebbene
questi questi dati in realtà
nascondono delle storie
e L'abbondanza di questi dati sta
cambiando anche il modo in cui queste
storie vengono raccontate sta cambiando
il modo in cui si fa il mestiere di
giornalista
parliamo quindi di data giornalismo e
quello di cui vorrei parlare oggi io
data giornalismo che non è altro che
l'applicazione del metodo scientifico
quindi matematica statistica al lavoro
del giornalista che ora è quella figura
che va a scovare i dati li analizza li
correla tra di loro per dare
all'inchiesta l'articolo alla storia
Maggiore obiettività
non è un fenomeno
recentissimo è un fenomeno che nasce
negli Stati Uniti a Detroit Alla fine
degli anni sessanta
in contrapposizione a quello che era
definito giornalismo narrativo dove il
giornalista Era visto come una figura
una specie di romanziere
Ebbene si chiama Alla fine degli anni
sessanta c'era una rivolta una protesta
degli scontri tra persone di colore a
Detroit e polizia un giornalista voleva
capire la natura di questi scontri e con
quei pochi dati a disposizione riuscì a
confutare il fatto l'idea che ha
protestare a scendere in strada fossero
solamente le persone più frustrate più
ai margini della società non era vero la
protesta riguardava tutti
Ebbene
da allora perché il dato aggiornatismo
potesse affermarsi diventare più vicino
a più persone ci sono voluti circa 40
anni
e questo è conciso Con l'avvento di
Internet e quindi quella possibilità di
pubblicare e di trovare una grandissima
quantità di dati online
parliamo di Open data quei dati pubblici
caricati online che tutti non solo i
giornalisti possono scaricare modificare
correlare tra di loro e utilizzare
liberamente e questo fenomeno di Open
data va intrecciarsi con un altro
fenomeno che è quello dell'open
government ossia l'apertura del
patrimonio informativo pubblico
perché per avere Maggiore trasparenza
della macchina amministrativa per
coinvolgere maggiormente i cittadini
nella vita pubblica per far sapere ai
cittadini lo stato di salute della
propria città o del proprio Paese
Guardate che questo è importantissimo al
giorno d'oggi e non solo
non solo i cittadini ma gli Open data
possono servire anche ai nostri stessi
amministratori che spesso guidano la
macchina amministrativa
fari spenti di notte al buio Ebbene gli
Open dati Open data possono servire come
la luce di un faro per guidare scelte
politiche e amministrative in tutte le
città in tutti i paesi
alcuni di voi diranno ma io ho paura di
condividere i miei dati io non so che
fine fanno i miei dati e avete ragione
emblematico il caso di Cambridge
analytica non so quanti di voi lo
conoscano Ma questa società di ricerche
nel 2016 è stata in grado di
collezionare una grandissima quantità di
dati sfruttando anche una falla di
Facebook
per influenzare le elezioni politiche
negli Stati Uniti così come il processo
di brexit
Ebbene Allora
proprio per questo motivo
diventa ancora più importante
il lavoro del data giornalista così come
gli Open data perché possono servire da
antidoto a questi tentativi di
manipolazione delle masse una sorta di
contropotere
Io non penso
che voi vogliate mangiare questo pacco
di pasta così com'è crudo quindi
immaginate un po' il lavoro del data
giornalista come il lavoro di colui che
sceglie questo pacco di pasta tra tanti
lo compra lo porta a casa lo cucina e lo
serve a tavola per nutrire
consapevolezza e trasparenza
ora Mi direte va bene
Ma perché io sono su questo palco che
cosa c'entro io con i dati e con il
giornalismo
Ebbene
ci sono tre momenti tre indizi della mia
vita personale che mi hanno avvicinato a
queste due passioni
il primo indizio in realtà è un nome
nello
era mio nonno ma anche il gommista del
paese Ebbene ma soprattutto era la
persona che ogni giorno portava
quell'oggetto sacro che è il Giornale
quotidiano dentro casa e la persona che
mi ha avvicinato alla lettura degli
articoli e alla scrittura degli stessi
Non finirò mai di ringraziarlo
il secondo momento è la visione di un
film
Quarto potere di Orson Wells un film
degli anni 40 Ebbene Grazie a questo
film ho capito l'importanza della stampa
e del giornalismo in grado di
influenzare l'opinione pubblica Quarto
potere Non a caso perché a fianco dei
tre poteri tradizionali legislativo
esecutivo e giudiziario
e infine c'è il terzo momento che
coincide con il mio ingresso nel mondo
del lavoro dove ho potuto scoprire e
apprezzare il valore che c'è dietro ogni
dato soprattutto i dati che attraversano
le nostre reti di telecomunicazioni
Ebbene
a un certo punto mi sono detto mi sono
chiesto
Come posso sfruttare queste mie passioni
per raccontare la città dove sono nato e
cresciuto che appunto Rieti
Come posso fare per valutare l'operato
dei nostri amministratori
per evidenziare i punti di forza e i
punti di debolezza di questa città
Ebbene Io all'inizio ho iniziato a
titolo personale ero io che volevo
conoscere quello che succedeva in questa
città solo successivamente con vari
passaggi ho deciso di condividere questa
mia passione queste competenze creando
il progetto Open di Rieti un progetto no
profit che cerca di indagare la realtà
di Rieti fare piccole inchieste che si
basano su Tre criteri sono data driven
ossia sfruttano quei pochi dati a
disposizione sulla nostra città
seconda caratteristica che riguardano
temi di attualità temi che interessano
Tutti i cittadini o categorie di
cittadini e infine
sono articoli inchieste
raccontate in maniera semplice
accessibile
Ebbene
progetto come Open Rieti In realtà ce ne
sono migliaia in tutta Italia in tutto
il mondo
ce ne sono in continuazione
Ma questi progetti
si basano su le stesse logiche e in
questo momento storico una di queste è
una risposta l'eccessiva polarizzazione
del dibattito pubblico con i dati
riusciamo ad avere maggiore obiettività
maggiore trasparenza è per questo che
oggi a me piace parlare di data
journalism come un fenomeno globale
perché non importa
che risorse si hanno a disposizione In
quale luogo del mondo si fa data
giornalismo Quali sono gli intenti per
cui si fa da journalist ma il Data
journalist ha un potere rivoluzionario E
quando dico rivoluzionario non sto
scherzando
immaginate la più grande caso di data
journeys nella storia The Panama papers
dove
400 giornalisti di 80 paesi hanno
lavorato insieme per quello che è
risultato il più grande scandalo
finanziario della storia portando alle
dimissioni di ministri primi ministri
oppure pensate al network europeo di
giornalisti investigativi
che sono stati in grado due anni fa di
analizzare i cambiamenti climatici di
100 mila città in tutta Europa negli
ultimi 40 anni per asserire che il
cambiamento climatico c'è è vicino a noi
e riguarda tutti noi e guardate sono
coinvolte anche i comuni e le province
di questo territorio
per arrivare fino al caso locale
appunto per Rieti e con quei pochi dati
a disposizione scoprire ad esempio che
la provincia di Rieti è la provincia in
Italia che a maggior numero in
percentuale di anziani fragili
oppure che Rieti Città dell'Acqua vede
due terzi dell'acqua e messa nella rete
idrica disperdersi bene piccole
inchieste gocce nel mare che dovrebbero
far agire i nostri amministratori
e vedete
perché progetti come Open Rieti possano
crescere
moltiplicarsi a fermarsi
c'è bisogno di una cosa
che vengano liberati i dati vengano
pubblicati sempre più dati troppo spesso
questi dati rimangono nei cassetti dei
nostri amministratori o quando va bene
Sono pubblicati online
attraverso PDF illeggibili
non solo i dati non sono scartoffie non
è qualcosa di arido i dati servono per
abitare consapevolmente la realtà e
parallelamente è necessario lavorare a
una cultura del dato per far capire il
valore che c'è dietro ogni singolo dato
questo vale soprattutto per le nuove
generazioni perché sempre più persone
soprattutto giovani possano Avvicinarsi
a questo pacco di pasta che se cucinato
bene è il cibo più sano che ci sia
Grazie
[Applauso]